attól az embertől, aki éjjel nem tudott
pihenni, nem tudta kialudni magát,
reggel nehezen indul, akkor attól az
embertől várjuk el azt, hogy
gyakorlatilag csúcsteljesítményt tudjon
leadni úgy fizikálisan vagy akár
mentálisan? Ez már egy elképzelhetetlen
dolog. Itt jön be az, hogy akkor
próbálja ezt a következő napját [zene]
valamivel kompenzálni, például azzal,
hogy megiszik hat kávét egy nap, amit
egész nap folytat, ami már kihatása lesz
a következő éjszakai alvás minőségére
is. És akkor belekerültünk megint ebbe
az ördöki spirálba, hogy ez akkor megint
a következő nap is rosszul fog aludni,
következő nap is 6- nyolc kávét fog
meginni, következő nap is ingerékenyebb,
nem tud fókuszálni, és akkor ez így megy
éveken vagy akár évtizedeken keresztül.